primeras tensiones entre Bruselas y el
nuevo ejecutivo italiano la comisión
europea ha pedido en un comunicado el
desembarque urgente inmediato de las más
de 200 personas que se encuentran en
el barco de médicos Sin fronteras que
esperan durante días a poder desembarcar
en el puerto más cercano durante casi
una semana en estado cerca de los
puertos italianos Esperando poder
desembarcar finalmente el gobierno
italiano aceptó el desembarco de las
personas más vulnerables básicamente
niños y mujeres pero tras las negativas
italiana poder desembarcar a todo el
mundo se ha acercado a las costas
francesas pero en un cruce de
acusaciones el gobierno francés asegura
que debía ser Italia quien Tendría que
haber aceptado de primera instancia a
todos los migrantes al ser el puerto más
cercano al respecto de la comisión
europea recuerda las obligaciones
humanitarias que tienen todos los
gobiernos se pide la cooperación de
todos los estados miembros porque lo que
está en juego son vi humanas la comisión
europea propuso una reforma de la
propuesta sobre el asilo y la migración
en la Unión Europea pero yo era desde
hace dos años bloqueada debido a la
división entre los países pero esta
nueva crisis en migratoria demuestra las
divisiones que hay en la Unión Europea y
que la situación puede ser más difícil
ahora con el nuevo ejecutivo de Georgia
meloni